Fact: An Anti-social is someone who doesn't care and violates others while in asocial is someone who doesn't like to socialize
I am guilty of making this mistake and confusing the two terms too before
I used to think that an anti-social refers to someone who doesn't like to socialize
But it turns out that in the field of psychology the proper term for someone who doesn't like to talk is called an asocial
anti-social behavior or anti-social personality disorder ASPD
is diagnosed as a personality disorder in which the person exhibits a lack of conscience for wrong-doings
an individual's personality becomes overwhelmed by an abnormal
mentality that causes negative patterns of behavior
ASPD, typically manifests during late childhood to early adolescence and continues into adulthood
according to the National Institute of health NIH
people who are diagnosed with antisocial behavior often display patterns of not only resistance to authority
but also frequent manipulation
exploitation and violation of rights of others
The exact cause of ASPD is unknown because there are many genetic and environmental
Factors that affect the development of this disorder a person is a greater risk of developing anti-social personality
if they are male, was abused as a child, have parents who also have ASPD, or
grew up with alcoholic adult figures
children with ASPD tend to display cruelty towards animals as well as have a high tendency to enjoy setting
illegal fires
symptoms that manifest in adults include frequent bursts of anger, arrogance, manipulation with remorse,
aggressive behavior and violent tendencies, no regard to personal safety or the safety of others and
lack of guilt or regret of any wrong-doings
some examples anti-social behavior include but are not limited to
harassing, conning, lying, bullying, etc. others, here's a list.
However in my own non-professional opinion
someone who is anti-social carries similar characteristics as
psychopaths namely someone who hurts others without any clear or logical motives. On the other hand
asocial is a term to describe a person's behavior that is characterized by the deliberate avoidance of social interaction
people who are diagnosed as a social tend to be inconsiderate or quite hostile towards others
asocial behavior is frequently observed in people who suffer from personality autism spectrum or
mood disorders some include schizophrenia, depression,
autism, asperger syndrome and social anxiety disorder
Here are some questions to ponder about
How does anti-social behavior link to psychopathy?
What is the line between someone who is just displaying anti-social behaviors because they are still young or having personal problems,
versus someone with early signs of psychopathy?